how's it going resume yeah today we're
gonna play Sims - how long ago was that
so we're gonna create any family today
we call it the YouTube verse let's
create myself first nice booty but that
is not how I look like I like her she's
wearing the wedding whale um Felix I am
a man last time I checked I would say
this is the most me oh god don't smile
please I just [ __ ] love wearing this
hat man it's my favorite hat so carry
automation the guy who did the forest
animation
he showed me a really nice glitch in
this game and alright we're going with
something weird here
oh god that that chin though no um you
can reset the sliders by I don't know
how they didn't figure this out cuz it's
so obvious but yeah you can pretty much
do the same [ __ ] over and over and over
okay where did my eyes go that's really
creepy there you go that's better
oh he keeps getting fatter this is
sitting still all day making YouTube
videos just taking a toll on me
I don't don't smile please it's it's for
the best of both of us
how about we have the smallest nosing in
infinity it really looks great
how about just a really [ __ ] smiley
mouth Halle iPad hi Joanne it's me Felix
get me cash yeah reset the eyes oh god I
skip going in so nasty
where's the smile there we go that's a
smile well you can see the eyes now
wonderful oh hi Joe oh god okay okay
okay
oh my god oh that night noticed though
hi hi I'm penny pie I have three mouths
I think kind of look like a shark I
don't know why give those really kawaii
Sugoi anime eyes whoa their eyes be
popping meth they really be coming when
senpai notice you like I said before
subtlety is the key to beauty I think
we're really founded here oh my god
you're so pretty that's me that's me all
right let's just change your clothes
really quick a little bit of subtle
stubble I have there we go there we go
okay it looks even better naked look at
that that hair cut my hair cut my
turn-ons our bathing suits and my
turn-ons our muscles and [ __ ] pretty pie
is ready let's create Edgar me and Edgar
in my hat
oh my god it's Edgar already so we have
a pug in here yeah we do all right cool
oh god what the [ __ ] oh you can see this
little tongue goes through bread guy can
you see his brain I can see its prey
what the [ __ ] no god what have I done
really really really what is that my
nightmares can't compare to this oh god
we can make it so bad I physically can't
make anymore changes to this it's
impossible for his face out nevermind oh
god
nevermind me and Edgar I don't even cook
and see him I bet he's on the floor yeah
I'm looking at him like door slam [ __ ]
that's right let's create my wonderful
and beautiful girlfriend amatzia
that's Oh Oh ever so pretty she is
why is she a boy oh that's why there we
go I can customize this without
glitching and it's already I can already
watch that is that it's not okay man oh
don't look so angry max might say I'm
sorry for doing this but
ah much don't kill me please I've gotta
get those cowboy eyes I'll make sure she
has the cowboy guys so angry Oh God
those eyes be popping man which planet
are you from
I could I could I could spend my entire
life playing this this is the best thing
ever happening to my life just look at
that isn't that the best EA you make the
best games man
it's nothing can compare to this nothing
oh god please don't smile I can see the
stars in your eyes no Lily I can see
they're right inside they're freaking
gigantic all right it looks so good
[ __ ] forgot ah sweet as the songs in
this game are I was like where our eyes
for a moment
[ __ ] really my scene where did your face
go might say what did you do um okay
that's my okay uh
turn-ons she likes bow ties and spatulas
and she doesn't like oh I actually know
that she doesn't like minors such a
beautiful couple how aren't we the
perfect match let's create polka Chan as
well
okay Chan girl which is you guessed it
another pug where the [ __ ] did you go no
I forgot Chanyeol chakyar okay Cho is
very fat so I think we should do
something with it my god maja you've put
on quite a lot oh my god oh my gosh this
is the best thing ever I can't I just
can't
oh my god this is this is free this game
is free anyone can do this this is gonna
revolutionize the gaming industry like
holy [ __ ] okay well let's focus on all
right let's go let's move in
okay there needs to be an adult in here
so I guess we'll make can I please play
now thank you
oh my god hello goodbye yeah ma yeah you
should come and see our family okay here
we go
amazing amazing so that's me I don't I
don't know
wait okay so this how do I go to me yeah
head gang okay so this is me how do you
like me and you're playing with Bogut an
are you like for your chance this is all
over wait that's all if you stop playing
with Priya Chen me anyway that's your
face yes like big and beautiful life oh
I who cares
okay I'm style change it I love your
eyes liquor they follow ya
wait let's watch Edgar he's also very
creepy ed guy I said gay what is he
doing yes how is he holding haha
oh we're communicating we're not
technically day-off we're not oh oh
let's hug friendly hug watch it oh you
got turned down for what hahaha don't
all right bris got after and that one
there let me know if you want me to keep
playing this I could create some other
youtubers and we can have all this
beautiful family together it was a long
time ago I played Sims 2 so it could be
a fun game to keep playing go ahead and
leave a like if you enjoyed watching
this episode and thank you for leaving a
comment press as always thanks for being
a bro-bro fish